[Música]
y llega el momento de hablar de revista
de prensa esto por supuesto con rosa
pérez más de euros a bienvenida muy buen
día iniciamos entonces en francia ya
perfilando los un poco a estas
elecciones presidenciales que va a tener
lugar la primera vuelta el 10 de abril
vamos con una investigación exclusiva
del periódico francés le monde como los
militantes de eric se me hinchan
artificialmente la presidencia y la
presencia de su candidato en twitter
buenos días efectivamente un grupo de
periodistas de lemont lo que han querido
averiguar es como previamente a
presentar su candidatura al frente de
éste para nuevo partido la reconquista
del 5 de diciembre el ix de moore llegó
a ser tendencia en twitter en francia en
una decena de ocasiones entonces se
ponen a analizar miles de tweets que
llevaban el hashtag o hashtags
relacionados con eric fémur y que
llegaron a ser pues está tendencia en
twitter francia uno de estos hashtags
analizados por ejemplo para mencionar
una de las partes de esta investigación
es la de la fama de que se moja las
mujeres con temor entonces analizan los
usuarios que twittearon con este hashtag
que finalmente llegó a ser número 5 en
las tendencias de francia bien pues se
encuentran que de entre 23 mil tweets
con esta almohadilla pues descartando
los retweets que en múltiples ocasiones
provienen de mismas cuentas que en
cuestión de pocos minutos retuitean
cientos de veces pues si cogen solamente
los tweets se encuentran que la mitad
forman parte de una estrategia
organizada por militantes de la campaña
desde moore que incluso los los propios
encargados de la estrategia digital del
candidato explican estas técnicas a
través de distintas páginas web y que de
estos 23.000 sólo hay 80 tweets
orgánicos pertenecientes pues realmente
a mujeres que muestran a su apoyo al
candidato usando una fotografía y pues
distintas imágenes y preguntando al
responsable de esta campaña los
periodistas se encuentran con la
siguiente respuesta el responsable dice
quedan menos de 90 días la elección
presidencial no tenemos tiempo de
cuestionarnos tanto lo importante es
desplegar la campaña lo máximo posible y
seguimos calentando entonces los motores
de cara a estas elecciones
presidenciales continuamos con la
extrema derecha de francia una exclusiva
de rtl rosa dice marín lepén obtiene uno
de obtiene de un banco un caro un
préstamo de 106 millones de euros para
financiar así su campaña exacto de esta
noticia de la que se hacen eco distintos
medios de comunicación tanto en francia
como en españa y otros medios europeos
lo que se desprende es esta cooperación
que no es un secreto para nadie entre
las distintas redes de la extrema
derecha en europa
este texto explica como marín al 'plan y
seguro por reagrupación nacional ante la
imposibilidad según dicen de encontrar
la financiación en francia recurren a
bancos de otros países de la unión
europea porque desde 2017 pues la es ley
francesa implica que sólo se pueden
acceder a préstamos dentro del propio
grupo comunitario y finalmente pues
explica el vínculo que
pues jugado un papel en el acceso a este
crédito entre viktor orbán el polémico
ultraderechista
presidente de hungría y pues es la
candidata presidencia rosa usted que es
de barcelona y todos los turistas que
han ido a visitar a su ciudad natal qué
pasaría si no estuvieran más esas grúas
en la sagrada familia nosotros podemos
ver realmente la sagrada familia
finalmente lista rosa pues es toda una
polémica porque las últimas pues fechas
apuntan a que el 2026 de 2027 podría
darse por finalizada este monumento que
es el paradigma de pues la problemática
que enfrenta la ciudad de barcelona
frente a este modelo de turismo de masas
y es esta dualidad porque por un lado
pues supone grandes ingresos para la
ciudad de hecho el 14 por ciento del pib
de la ciudad depende del turismo pero al
mismo tiempo supone una alteración de la
vida vecinal y de la vida cotidiana para
los residentes de barcelona bien lo que
explica este artículo es que en estos
140 años que lleva en marcha este
proyecto diseñado por antoni gaudí han
habido muchos de duda entre sí valía la
pena terminar o no con este monumento
que es ya el más visitado de españa sin
embargo digamos que el último eslabón
que hay que decidir pues como cómo
continúa esto implica la construcción de
una escalinata que para materializarse
implicaría el derribo de toda una
manzana y la expulsión de sus hogares de
unos tres mil vecinos y ya digamos
citando a uno de los afectados por este
plan en este texto leemos es una zona de
turismo masificado que no está
regularizado que no hay comercios de
proximidad como supermercados o
panaderías ya que estos han sido
sustituidos por tiendas de souvenirs
estoy en total desacuerdo con el plan
urbanístico gaudí nunca planeó esto yo
creo que nos vamos a conformar solamente
con que terminen las torres y ya no
tomaron la foto con esas grúas rosa y
cerramos con un tema que hemos tratado
reiteradamente aquí los problemas y los
retos del grupo de marchó kerber
efectivamente y es que tras presentar
sus cifras del último trimestre de 2021
algunos analistas ya ven estos números
como el principio del fin
por primera vez desde que fue creado
facebook ha perdido el número de
usuarios diarios que usan la aplicación
aún así las cifras de personas que
siguen conectadas a la plataforma
principal de marca shaker ven son pues
enormes de hecho ha perdido un millón de
usuarios diarios pero se mantiene en
1.929 millones de personas que usan su
aplicación pues cotidianamente y entre
los distintos puntos que se analizan
como motivo de esta caída es la falta de
relevancia de facebook entre los jóvenes
que preferirían alternativas como tik
tok y la imposibilidad que tiene
facebook también de adquirir nuevas
aplicaciones porque recordemos el grupo
está siendo explotado por la autoridad
de la competencia de eeuu rosa oyó
hablar de la gran renuncia o la gran
división por supuesto me parece muy
interesante entonces el invito a que se
quede ahí conmigo porque ese va a ser
nuestro primer tema del día